fumer ça tu vois là ça tu tellement que
fumer tue deux fois plus tous les ans
que ce cas tu es le comique 19 et ça il
faut avoir ce sera en tête aussi ça
c'est un bon indicateur
c'est que tous les ans on tue deux fois
plus de monde par le tabac que ce cas tu
es le colis de 19 alors maintenant bien
sûr les aérosols sont quelque chose
qu'on connaît bien le professeur antoine
flahault connaît très bien les
gouttelettes de flügel puisque c'est
comme ça globalement que se transmet
quoi c'est un des vecteurs de la grippe
les aérosols sont se propage et reste en
l'air dans les milieux confinés
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
l'une des raisons pour laquelle il y en
a beaucoup d'autres c'est multifactoriel
mais l'une des raisons pour laquelle en
hiver lorsqu'on vit dans des espaces
confinés
il y a en général une grande probabilité
qu'ils arrivent des épidémies de grippe
et ces épidémies de grippe bizarrement
lorsqu'on ouvre les fenêtres lorsqu'on
essaye d'aérer l'espace est bien le
risque est moins grand alors j'aimerais
justement revenir sur cet aspect là
puisque l'inde est l'un des aspects de
cette crise a été justement ce qu'on a
appelé le confinement et à un moment
donné donc pendant la crise on nous a
dit il faut vous confiné et bien
probablement que ce confinement a
sûrement joué un facteur accélérateur de
la propagation du
du virus en tout cas intra familiales
voilà donc il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'incohérences dans cette
gestion de crise
[Musique]